les peintures des grands maîtres des
sculptures renommée des concerts
emblématique tout cela est à découvrir
dans la maison de reuilly oui bien sûr
grâce à un serveur informatique quelques
tablettes et un vidéoprojecteur la
petite commune du berry offre à tous
une plongée dans l'histoire de l'art il
ya des vidéos
le cartel rue y investit dans le musée
numérique du ministère de la culture
c'est la seule commune de l'indre a
proposé la micro folie voire la
population de riz qui va pouvoir accéder
à des oeuvres qui n'ont pas forcément la
possibilité d'accéder facilement faut se
rendre à paris où parfois même dans
d'autres musées nationaux voire
internationaux
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on peut
qu'on peut y aller là on l'aimé a
apporté 2
doit avec la tablette on arrive
on arrive à toucher la clau compte c'est
pas possible
à paris ça que c'est quelque chose qui
qui
qui permet je pense de toucher les
jeunes par on va dire par l'aspect
tablette mais ça va aussi toucher reste
de la population parce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas accès facilement en
temps normal et là on a dans une petite
ville de 2000 habitants
on espère ramener aussi des gens de
l'extérieur peut-être des gens disent ou
en plus des 1600 oeuvres d'art virtuelle
la maison de reuilly assure la promotion
des artistes locaux et dès la rentrée le
public scolaire sera invité à s'emparer
de cet outil numérique au service de
l'art